若干お時間がございますけど
ご質問などありますでしょうか
えっと じゃあすいません
後ろの方先で  すみません
質問です 座って瞑想の時は
あの ちょっとあの大きな声でお願いします
座ってする瞑想の時には
自分の感覚ですね 体の各部の感覚を日常の確認して
それは痛みとか痺れとかそういう感じで言うんですが
歩く瞑想の場合ですね
やはり同じように感覚に関してそれは意識するんでしょうか
歩く瞑想の場合はね 左足上げます
下ろします 下ろしますと言ってるでしょ
はい じゃあそのそういう感覚を感じた時は
それはもうそのまま放置OKという
まああの言葉掛けなくても構いません
足の動きの感覚だけ感じてやろうと思った方がいいんです
痛みが生まれたら まあそこはまあわかっておけば十分です
あまり心配したり気にしたりしないで
まあ歩く瞑想はする  そちらの方に集中してやるということ
そうそう  あの ちょうど今日の話の中で
人生を小さなコマごとに見るというお話があって
なるほどなと思ったんですけど
うーん なんかですね 何か名人がいると
例えば大工の名人とか
弓の名人とか 一つのことに秀でた人がいると
きっと他にもいろいろ知ってるんじゃないかと思って
一芸に秀でた人は多芸に通じるみたいな
つい色々聞きたく 知ってるんじゃないかな
例えば将棋の名人だと
将棋だけじゃなくて人生についても詳しいんじゃないかなとかって思って聞いてしまうところなんですけど
そういうのは  そういうのはちょっと危ないっていうことなんですよ
気をつけた方がいい  気をつけた方がいいって
あれは秀でた能力があるところはびっくりする
だからそちらにはもう徹底的にもう学んだ方がいいんですね
しかし まあ先生はこういうところを一生かけてすごい素晴らしいんですということで信頼して
もう自分を自分を投げ捨てて学ぶ
だから全て知ってるんだぞと思ったら
先生のだらしないところが見てみると何か嫌になったりして
なんだこれはとかと思ったら
自分学ぶこともできなくなっちゃうんですね
そこはまあ そこはもう何のことなく無視することはできるんですね
分けることはできるんです
逆に先生を守ってあげることもできるんです
先生 そんなことやっちゃうとまずいんだからとかね
やめましょうよとか 正当なのに言えるんです
先生 名人だからね これかっこ悪いんだよと
可愛い弟子が言うことだから
あ そうかそうかということで先生守られます
全体的全て知ってるんだぞと思ったら
もう弟子もダメージ受けるし
もう先生も大変ですよ
時々弟子入りを拒む時もありますよ
弟子入りして人は全面的に育ててほしいと思うんだけど
師匠にはそんな能力ないんです
もう嫌だと拒むんですね
それで問題ない人だと分かったら
じゃあいいよと言うんです
そういう先生たちの立場からもそれがあるんですね
そうすると立場が逆になると
こういう過剰な期待をしてくるような弟子は
師匠としては断った方がいいっていうこと
そういうことになる 何でも教えてくれると思ったら
もう断った方がいいってことになるんです
だからもう何でもいいんだから
あなたからこれだけ学びたいやというならば
あんた命でも賭ける もう命にでも賭けてでもそれを教えてくれるならばったら
もう他は期待してないでしょ
OK なんです そうすると
教える側の人だって本当に学ぶんだから気分がいいし
いい弟子ができたっていうことになるし
その人も先生から何でもっていうことを期待してないんだから
先生は愛嬌になってくると
先生ちょっとこれはやめてくださいとかね
強引に酒瓶を持って行ったりとかね
強引に家に連れ戻したりとすることもできますよ
そうすると本格的な師弟関係で
もう親と子の状態になるんですよ
だから人間の世界ではやっぱりそういう風な師弟関係なんですよ
結局は弟子に守られることにもなるんです
で ないの 仏教の世界だけ
ブッダが言うんですよ
普通世界ではね もう弟子に守られる先生たちもいますけどね
まあそれは教えと人格の問題ですと
仏教はそれないんだよと
あんた方 私のことを守らなくても結構ですと
それは仏陀の場合はそれは逆ですけど
まあ仏教は生きることを教えることだから
結局は全面的に何でも真似て学ぶ世界ですよ
それでも我々弟子たちの世界ではかなり気をつけるんですよ
私たちも もう全く師弟関係でしょ
我々が出家したら 先生から学んで学んで学んで大量のことを学ぶんですけど
まぁ完璧に全て学ぶってことでもないんです
なんか気に入らんことをやってやると
何のことなく言うんです
先生に 嫌味を言うんです
だからといって長老たちが全然そこは嫌がらないんです
だから人間としては まあいろいろちょこちょこちょっとところは結構あるということですから
まあそこはまあ置いといて
学ぶべきところだけ学ぶと
非常によくわかったんですけれど
深掘りうちに今日のお話の中で猿真似っていう言葉があって
猿真似 猿真似って自分がなくて
周りにある程度学んでくれば
これは学んで これは学ばなくていいっていうのがわかると思うんですけど
わからないうちはつい色んな悪いことも学んでしまう
師匠の先生の悪い癖まで学んでしまうっていうことがあると思うんですけど
それはある程度しょうがないんですか？ うーん
まあやっぱり小学生ぐらいになってからはそこはダメですよね
ちっちゃな子供の場合は気をつけた方がいいんですね
で 私も時々子供たちと一緒に遊んだりする場合も
子供はすごい小さいんだったら
自分がすごいしっかり気をつけるんです
何でも行儀よくやるんです
中学生ぐらいだったら
できるだけあんなことやるんです
なぜかというと 猿真似するなよということなんです
学ぶものはあるんですけど
だからといって私はそれを完璧に学ぶ
学びようがありませんという
小さな子供の場合はそれしません
で 赤信号だから止めましょうとかね
食べる時は行儀よく食べましょうとかね
なぜかというと 小さい連中はもう全部真似るんですよ
でも大きくなってくると選ばなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで私はもう一つポイントありますけど
人を評価する場合は 例えば将棋のすっごい腕がいいということで
すごいとはそんなに思わないんです
例えば弓でもう金メダル取ったと
それはそんなにだから何やということになるんです
だってその人一生かけてますから
それに 金メダルぐらい取れなきゃ意味がないぞという気分なんです
しかし その人を人間として見ると
あら いいところあるんだと落ち着いているんだ
物事を明確に考えているんだとかね
そこはすごくいい人だと
すごい能力あると評価するんです
だからアーチェリーであろうか
将棋であろうか その世界から人間として何か学んでならば
そこら辺がすごいんです
笑い芸人っていうのは
私にはものすごくバカバカバカらしくて意味もないんだけど
でも結構評価する人物はいるんです
人を笑わせるではなくて
その裏でかなり人生 生き方持っていて
世の中をよく観察して
ただそれを言う時だけものすごく面白おかしく人を喜べるように言うだけで
これがすごい才能やと
よく演芸出てくる爆笑問題とかね
いるでしょ で かなり世の中のことをよく見てよく分かって
日本のことやら政治のことやらね
国際的なことやらね そこを喋ると面白くないしね
うるさいし それはあまり喋れませんだけど
そこをよくわかって その上でもう笑い芸人として活動すると
これはもう紛れもなく才能やと
ビートたけしさんもそうでしょうし
で 誰にも見せないんだけど
人生についてはかなりもう知ってるんですね
しかし やることは全部まあとんでもないことばっかりやってるんですけど
それがあえてわざとやっているんですね
だから 例えばビートたけしの映画っていうのは
ものすごい極限のバイオレンスでしょ？で
アメリカの映画もそこもう負けるんだよ
あの あのバイオレンスのレベルには
しかし しっかりと反対のことを言っているんです
もうなかなか才能だと
そういうことで 自分がの専門の世界から何か人間としても何か学んでいくならば
そこはものすごい才能として評価するべきなんですね
だからもうそういうものは無いってわけでもないんですね
あるいは将棋の人は何でもかんでも将棋の目で見ちゃうと
偏見だけで あの あまりよくないんでしょうしね
将棋のプロになった上で
生き方についても 人生についても何か学ぶということがあればありがたいです
だから そういうところがあれば学ぶ
なかったらなかったでいいんです
別に 人の歌で喜ぶならば
その人の歌唱力はすごい抜群だったらそれで十分ですよ
この人はもう書き事に依存しているんだとかね
裏で麻薬打ってるならどうでもいいんだ
そんなのは 勝手にしろよ
関係ないんだ あなたしっかりと歌えて
その自分のその人を喜ばせてあげる
それをしっかりやってくれれば
まあそれ職業ということでね
だから細ごとに物事を見るということでは
一応正しく生きていられます
正しく真似 真似の正しいやり方
真似っていうことは あの
これは避けられないんですよ
私たちはもう何でも真似で大人になっているんです
だから真似ることにケチつけちゃではあかんです
人から学ばなきゃただの猿でしょ
だからそれが人間の道なんですね
学ぶ 真似る 学ぶ 我々学ぶという言葉使いますけどね
学ぶということは だからこそ
そちら辺ですっごい真剣にならなくちゃいけないんです
学ぶべきものと 学んではならないものというところの能力は自己責任になります
はい  すいません  はい  事実を
現実をありのままに見るっていうのは難しいなって今日思ったんですけども
それは人生は山あり谷ありと
一般の仏教知らない人が見た場合
人も一緒見た時にですね
確かにあの この人それぞれに山があって谷があるように見えますよね
今言われて そういうことでしたねと
まあ普通の人が見ると確かに輝いてる時とか
落ち込んでる時とか あるように見えて
山あり谷ありっていうのは
まあ普通に見るとそういう風に思っちゃうと思うんですよ
でもそれは仏教から見たら真理じゃないっていうお話を聞いて
その現実をありのままに見るっていうのは結構難しいなって思いました
で まあ仏教の立場からいくと
やっぱり精進して その慈悲の心を持ったりとか
そういう心のままに絡みなくちゃいけない
そういう そういう立場から
その現実を見ていくっていうことが大切かなと
山あり谷ありということは真実ではないという話ではなくて
そんな程度のことじゃないんだと
お釈迦様発見したのは
山あり谷ありということは誰でも知っていることでしょう
だからお釈迦様 私は初めに発見しまったと言える？言えないでしょう
だから誰でも知っていることじゃないんですね
もう一つですね その人生に山あり谷ありっていうのを受け入れるってことは
その自分がその自分の弱い面をですね
認めているという 認めているというとおかしいですけども
できないこともしょうがないなというふうに
そういう弱い気持ちになっているといいますか
それがちょっと仏教的な立場じゃないなという
それはそうじゃない 仏教的な立場ではないんですね
山あり谷ありって人々は
このなんか時間に対して鈍感ですよ
あれ 何時間単位で何年単位で考えているんですかね
物事っていうのは瞬間で変化するでしょう
瞬間単位で見ると 山も谷もないでしょうに
例えばもう歳になったところで
あのもう代ではすごく苦しかったとかね
カップラーメンしか食べることできなかったとかね
これを波乱万丈人生やとか何って考えているんですかね
あれは だからそれ時間に対しての考えですよ
では物事は瞬間で 例えば秒で動いていると思ったら
山も谷もないでしょう
秒 秒で見れば そのその秒に我々は挑戦しなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから いつでもやらなくてはいけないこと
挑戦しなくちゃいけないことっていうのは
どんな秒にもあるんです
だから それに戦って戦って前へ前へ進んでいくだけなら
山あり谷ありじゃないんですよ
だから仏教は時間を長く取ってみたら
別に仏教とはね 財産がなくなったんだからといって
仕事がなくなったって気にもしないんです
だって秒単位で生きているんだから
それはないんです そういう現象
考えさえも だから年単位で物事を考える人にとっては
明日からあんた来なくてもいいよと言われると
もう大変どん底に落ち入っちゃうんです
仏教の人に明日から来なくていいやと言ったら
明日からそのべき他のことあるんです
だって会社に行かないでしょ？で
生きてるんだからね 明日今日はこれこれやりますよってことでもう忙しい
だからこの年単位で見ると
山も谷もあるんですけど
秒で秒で見ると そんなのもう暇がないんです
とにかく 次のこと 次のこと
次のことやらなくちゃいけない
病気になったら年前から考えると悔しいんですね
年前元気でもうすごい活発で体力あったのに
今は息苦しくて なんで惨めやと
それが年単位で物事を考える山あり谷あり世界なんですね
仏教徒だったらもう 胸が苦しくなったならば
じゃあそれでこうしましょうということで忙しいんです
じゃあちょっと胸が苦しくなった
じゃあさっさとお医者さんのところに行こうと
そこでもう電車で行くか
タクシーで行くか もう何て言いますか
救急車を呼ぶかとかね
その瞬間で真剣に考えるんだから
もう大変忙しいんです
そこで病院と言ったっても
どちらに行けばいいかと
じゃあもうかかりつけの病院があるならそちらに行くしかないでしょうとかね
で そのお医者さんに聞いて
いいところを紹介してもらおうとか
そんなところなかったら
さっさとインターネットでもそこら辺何かいい病院探しましょうとかね
そういうことで忙しいのであって
なんで俺が不幸かなとかね 10
年前こんなことなかった
だから常に明るいんですよ
活発なんですね だから止まりたなりっていうことは嘘っていう意味じゃなくて
それはどんな時間感覚で物事を考えるのかっていうことなんです 10
年感覚で考えたっても 10
年感覚で誰も生きてないんです
我々はもう一応スケジュールとか何とか作りますけど
今やること 今やること
今やることやってきてるだけだからね
そういうこと ありのまま見ることは難しい
難しいってはないんですよ
本当は一番簡単なありのままに見ることなんです
このね 我々のこの妄想のね
癖がなくならないとね
見られないだけで 一番簡単なのはありのままの見ることですね
何もやることもないでしょうに
考える必要ないでしょう
ありのままですからね
考えてみる人にとってはものすごい難しい
思考から解放された人にとっては
もうこんな楽なことはないんだ
ということになるんです
はい  ということは ということは
今の話の続きになるかどうかわかりませんけれども
ほとんど新聞とかですね
ジャーナルの経済面を見ると
経済はこうなる こうなるという予測がいろいろ出ますけれども
ということはほとんど嘘という風に考えていいような感じがするのですが
いかがですか  今までの話を見るとそうでしょう
結局は 言う通りにならないでしょう
ただ 体にはそういう観察能力がないんです
仏教的に予測したら びくっとにその通りがなるんですよ
昨日か前かこちらで同じこと言いましたけど
木曜日もね 私はちょっとしたことである人にね
バイオディーゼルの計画をやってる人にね
今あなた方乗ってますけど
これはあまり危ないんだと
将来は大変なことになるんだと
それこそ自然破壊になるんだよと
でも本人はまあそんなのはもうすごい将来の話でしょう
でも 25年  20年ぐらい考えれば
まあそこはないでしょうと言ってもなっていた
私が予測したことはもうとっくになっていて
いわゆる高騰 食べ物の
私はこれはいくらなんでも早すぎやと
自分ももうちょっと遅くなってそうなるだろうと思ったんですけど
もう言ってすぐそうなってしまってるんですね
ということは まあ仏教的に物事を見ると
結構ズバリと当たるような予測ができるんじゃないかなと
結構今まで私はいろんな色々冗談で遊びでいろんなものを予測したりはするんですけど
もう結構当たります 宝くじ以外は
悪者ならもう何でも まあだから世の中ではね
時間的な考え方はね まああんまり正しくないんだからね
すごい言うことはその通りにはほとんどならない
イラク戦争を始めた時
私は今の状況を予測していたんです
今 サブプライム問題でアメリカで起きている問題とかね
イラク戦争始めるとね
あの野郎が戦争してこれからすっごいからお金奪ってやるぞではないかと
人殺しはただでは済みませんよと
賛成した国々はみんなそのこと払う羽目になるんだよと
で もう結局はあのイラク戦争やらいろいろアフガン戦争やら
そういうことにめっちゃ金なくなったんだから
こういう問題が起きたんです
では 殺しに参加した人も
参加しなかった人も 賛成した人も
反対した人も これから大変です
我々個人個人でね 仏教徒ではそんな大げさなことを考えてもね
我々個人ではもうあまり関係ないし
どうすることもできないし
原油価格が上がること
我々にはどうすることもできないし
私たちは今の瞬間 今の瞬間で物事を考えてしっかり生きるということで
あんまりこの波あり谷ありということは
もうそんなにも気にすること
気にする必要なくなっちゃうんです
あの食べ物の値段がすごく上がったんだ
どうしよう どうでもいいんですよ
あるお金で何か買って食べちゃえばね
あるいはみんなでね いろいろ自分のポットの上でもよろしいしね
何かちょこちょこっと面白くね
食べ物を作ったりとか
で いくらでもね もう空き地があるしね
そこら辺である人は何か作って友達に配ったりして
友達が作ったものを自分でもらったりしてとか
そういう楽しみもある
そうすると別に値段が高いということはそんなに気にすることはなくなっちゃうんです
だからその都度どうしましょうかと考えれば
問題は解決するんです
インドに対してね アメリカが経済制裁したでしょ
その結果としては インドはとんでもない経済大国になってしまっちゃったんです
破壊するだろうと思ってたんですけど
だからそういうふうなまぁアプローチあるんですよ
最終的にアメリカは経済制裁をやめてインドに助けてもらうということになって
この間の記事読みましたけど
アウトソーシングという今は何でもアウトソーシングやと
アメリカの法律関係の弁護士さんたちはほとんどインド人で
インドで事務所 女の子たちとかね
弁護士になっちゃって
インドでは別にもういちいちやらない
裁判に行ったりとか で
アメリカの裁判をやってるんです
アウトソーシングで そのそのセクションがきちっと調べてデータを調べて
どういう風に組み立て弁論するのかと
もうインターネットでぞっと情報を流す
その会社に それでこちらにお金が入ってくる
だからその状況で何をするべきかということを
インド人もあまり長い目でものを見ないんだからね
それはバカだから 仏教だからではないんです
で 今日儲かればいいかという哲学ですから
だから今日どうすれば儲かるのかということしかインド人は考えてないんです
これでうまくいってるんです
アメリカに対立することでもなく
別に経済敗走といいですよ
別に痛くも痒くもない
痛くも痒くもなかったんです
どういうことかというと
この世界のスティールプロダクションという
何といいますか 鉄 鉄鋼
全部一人のインド人に買われる羽目になったでしょうに
イギリスの一番 え？ ジャガー
車のジャガー  ジャガーも
フォードが買収してジャガーは取っとこうと
インドのタタっていう
タタ会社 それからイギリスの伝統のあるなんとか酒
ジョニーウォーカー  ジョニーウォーカーじゃなくて
ウイスキーの一種か何とかの
すごい伝統があるんです
それはもうインド人ですよ
もう 買ってるんです あの経済制裁の結果です
それでね あの北朝鮮に対する経済制裁
北朝鮮の態度は何なのかと
インドの態度は何なのかと
やっぱり見方次第で山あり谷ありのない
ないんです あの日本ではね
あの この 何といいますか
この食物の値段がね ずっと上がっていて
外国は売らないことにしたりしてね
まあ大変大きな問題だと言いますけど
それは問題じゃないよと見てみてみたら
じゃあみんなで庭がある人は何か作りましょうと
バルコニーがある人はバルコニーでもいろいろ作りましょうということになったりして
お互いに友達同士でね
まああんたジャガイモ
じゃあ私はほうれん草作ろうとかね
そういう感じになってくると
もう何のことないんですよ
痛くも痒くも あれ 値段高いの？という
あ 知らなかった で 石油の値段にいたってもね
もういろいろ方法ありますよ
とにかくもう動かないで済むようにあらゆる工夫をすれば
会社がもう社員は雇うんだけど
みんな自分の家で仕事をしなさいと
ノートパソコンぐらい持ってるでしょうと
今はもうその時差サボったりすることできない
まあもうその場であの
あの 何というか チャットやらいろいろありますから
で ちゃんと例えば八時半になるともうコンピューター入れて
もうアクセスして もうログインして待っていれば
もうカメラ回しちゃえば仕事をしてるのがわかるでしょうに
だからデータを流して
また録って また直してなんてできますよ
だからそういうふうにね
まあいろいろ工夫すると集金する必要なくなっちゃうんですよ
なんで集金するんですかね
一箇所でね もうすごい
あれ あれ あの 何て言いますか
建物のレンタル料金になってますから
すごい高いでしょうね
電気代もかかるでしょうに
通勤もきついでしょうに
それで遅くまで仕事をして家に帰って
ものすごい時間かかって寝る時間もないでしょう
これでえらいことに石油の値段が上がっているんだからね
全部解放されます ああ
よかったと ものすごい今楽だと
ちゃんと寝られますよと
今日は十一時まで仕事をしたんだと
どうったことない 家の中だから
十時になってくるとノートをね
布団の中に持っていけばいいし
そのまま置いておいて
終わったらそれを消して寝ると
十分寝る時間はある で
休む時間もあるし 休み時間は電車に乗ってあっちこっち行くんじゃなくて
ずっと一箇所でパソコンばっかりいじってるんだから
そこら辺の公園でジョギングしたり
いろいろ運動したりして
それもOK でしょうし
そういうことで 一つの問題
問題起きるっていうのは時間長く見ると問題なんです
秒単位で見ると挑戦なんです
問題か挑戦かということなんです
だから仏教的な見方というのは挑戦で
これが挑戦だと 挑戦で見るんですね
はい そういうことで はい
ナマティという言葉はですね
曲げるとか屈するとか内面の方向に向けるという意味があると思うんですが
寄り付くとか寄り添うっていうような意味もあるんで
傾きするじゃない  まあまあ
脈絡によって入れて考えないとね
わからないんですけど
ナマティって傾くことですからね
より まあそんな大きな問題じゃないけどですよね
ナマがですね ナマってどういう言葉からできたかなと
ナマはそちらから出ているんです
寄り付くって何に寄り付くんだ
あれ 寄り付くことでもなくて
水と入れ物とのような関係なんですね
水の形はどんな形かと
形ないでしょうに 水には
それに合わせちゃう  入れ物の形ですね
水の形は そういうふうに認識する
何でも認識できるんだから
心に 例えば壁を認識する
本を認識すると 同じ視覚でしょ
でもそれなりに心が形変えないと見えないんです
だから我々の視覚には壁も見えて
本も見えるんです そういうふうに対象によって形をとるということ
はい それで終了しますか
はい 質問がなければ終了したいと思いますけど
ストーリーは何ページになった
よろしいですか  回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
彼を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の人々生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての人し生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そしてヴィパッサナーで
サンビティヨ ヴィパッジャントゥ サンバローゴ ウィナッサトゥ マテー バワント アンタラーヨ スキーディーガ
ユコー バワ バワトゥ サッバ マングラ ラッカントゥ サンバ デヴァタ サンバ ブンダーヌバーヴェーナ サンバ
ダンマーヌバーヴェーナ サッバ サンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー ソッティ バワントゥ テ アビワダナ シーリッサ
ニッチャン ワンダー パチャイナ チャッ
サローダンマ ワッダンティ アユ ワンノ スカーム バラーム
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
ありがとうございます